I've,
I've been telling people online in various
ways and in lectures that they should
start fixing up the world
by cleaning up the room.
And I wanted to just elaborate on that
a little bit before I get back to the
lecture itself.
So I'd say it's become this
Internet weird Internet meme,
you know,
and it's a joke and good,
it's a joke.
I really happy about the fact that so
much of this has got like the leaving of
humor and it's really important
because that's what stops things from
degenerating into,
into conflict humor.
And I was thinking about this idea of
cleaning up your room in relationship to
the mustard seed idea.
And you see the thing about
cleaning up your room,
this is also something I learned from
Carl Young and his studies on alchemy
because for young,
when the outcomist was attempting to make
the philosopher's stone and he was not
only engaged in the transformation
of the material world,
but he was engaged in a process of self
transformation that occurred at the same
time as the,
as the chemical trend,
as the chemical transformation.
So it was a psychological
work in some sense.
Let's say you want to sort out your room
and beautified cause the beauty is also
important.
And let's say that all you have is just
a little room like you're not rich,
you're poor and you don't have any power.
That's another thing.
But you've got your damn room and you've
got this space right in front of you.
You know that,
that that's a part of the cosmos that
you can come to grips with and you might
think,
well what's there in front
of you right in front of you?
And the answer to that is,
it depends on how open your eyes are,
that that's the proper answer.
Because you could say,
w William Blake said this,
for example,
eldest Huxley made comments that were
very similar that in a transcendent state,
you can see infinity in the finite.
And you might say,
well you can say,
and you can see infinity in
what you have within your grasp.
If you look and you could say,
maybe that's the case with your room.
And so you want to clean up your room.
Well.
Okay,
how do you do that?
Exactly?
Well,
the room is a room is a place to sleep.
And so if you set your room up properly,
then you figure out how to sleep and
when you should sleep and how you should
sleep.
And then you figure out when you
should wake up and then you figure out,
well what clothes you should wear because
they have to be arranged properly in
your dresser.
And then you have to have some
place to put your clothes.
And if you're going to have some clothes,
you have to figure out what you're
going to wear those clothes to do,
right.
And then that means that
you have to figure out what
you're going to do and then
your room has to serve that
purpose because otherwise
it isn't set up properly.
And if it doesn't set up,
if it doesn't serve your purposes,
you will be unhappy and
not happy in the room.
Because the way that we perceive the world
is as a place to move from point a to
point B in.
And then if the place that we're
in facilitates that movement,
then we're happy to be there.
And if the place that we're in serves
as an obstacle to that movement,
then we're unhappy to be there.
And so what it means to set up your room
is that you have to have somewhere to
go that's worthwhile.
Or You can't set up your room and then
your room has to be set up to facilitate
that.
And then the next thing is,
well,
maybe you have to make it beautiful,
but that's not easy,
right?
That means you have to have some taste.
And that doesn't mean
you have to have money.
It doesn't,
because you can be garish with money
and you can be tasteful with nothing.
All you need is taste and taste beats
money when it comes to beautifying things.
You know what I mean?
Not that money is
trivial because it's not,
the taste is crucial.
And people who are very artistically
oriented can make beautiful things out of
virtually nothing.
And not only that,
the literature suggests that if
you're going to make beautiful things,
putting real constraints on,
on what you allow yourself to do,
facilitates creativity instead
of interfering with it.
Because let's say you have to
make something out of nothing,
right?
Which I suppose would be a Godly Act,
You have to make something out of nothing
and you have to be creative in order
to do that.
And so then to beautify your room means
that you also have to develop your
capacity to be creative.
And so then you can make your room shine.
But then what'll happen is that
if your family isn't together,
they will interfere with that.
You will interfere with that because
you won't have the discipline to do it
properly.
But then when you start building this,
this,
this little microcosm of perfection
with what you have at hand,
then it'll evoke all the pathologies
of everyone in your household.
The wonder what the hell
you're up to in there.
And they won't necessarily
be happy because if you're,
if they're in a lowly place,
let's say,
and so are you,
and you're trying to move out of that
then that the higher you move out of that,
the more the place they're in looks bad.
And you might say,
well,
what they should do is celebrate
your victory over chaos and evil.
But that isn't what will happen.
What will happen instead is that they
will attempt to pull you back down.
They'll attempt to,
and I mean obviously all
families don't do that,
but,
but all families do that to some degree
and some families do almost nothing but
that.
And so what that means is that if
you're going to organize your room,
then you're going to have to
confront the devils in your house.
And that's often,
that's often a terrifying thing because
some of those devils have have lineages
that go back many,
many,
many generations.
And God only knows what you have to
struggle with in order to overcome that.
And so and so to sort yourself out into
fix up your room is a nontrivial matter.
You know,
and you,
you can do that.
You'll learn by doing that.
And then maybe you'll learn enough by
doing that so that you can fix up your
family a little bit.
And then having done that,
you'll have enough characters so that
when you try to operate in the world at
your job,
or maybe in the broader social spheres,
that you'll be a force for good instead
of harm because you'll have learned some
humility by noting just how difficult it
was to put your damn room together well
and yourself for that matter.
And so you'll proceed cautiously
with your eyes open towards the good.